it's a difficult time for these market  vendors even here in this one time  well-off neighborhood in Thessaloniki  people are buying only the barest of  necessities more and more small business  owners have had to close their doors  they're broke some now depend on food  donations to get by now it's nothing  behind these simple facades the mood is  explosive nothing is taken for granted  anymore not even the ability to pay the  electric bill I pay when I can and when  I can't I don't worry about it they  won't turn off the power because if they  do there'll be a revolution more  austerity measures could be on the cards  leading to more cutbacks it's a vicious  circle the result is just more poverty  every day we see more and more people  searching trash containers for something  to eat Greece's economic woes can be  felt at every market as the crisis  enters its eighth year for many people  poverty has become a daily reality